Dear Mr.
Marshal
High Chamber today is historic
because So far every project
Liberalizing abortion law in Poland
He dropped out on 1st reading.
there were such projects in total 23 from 93.
When the so-called abortion compromise was introduced
in our club
There is and will be no discipline.
a positions on the liberalisation of this right
are different yet we promised
that we will vote for all projects
and so it happened
We voted yes
so that we can have a substantive discussion in committee
which in a moment yy will be called
This is a great success.
coalition on October 15
but also Marshal Szymon Hołownia who
which at the moment
When there was risk
These projects will fall off.
He decided to move
gave us a moment to cool down and today we have a success
Coalition on October 15
I will be discussing this,
thank you.